kjd 15-time all-star back here on the
show how are you kg um well now how you
doing this you got it you have to give
Bernard King a hug for me I know that
that might be odd and awkward but as a
kid from New York City this guy is the
man and literally I get it I totally
understand there's some right there
which I'm gonna have to do a group hug
the hell the hell with just one huh I'm
have to hug everybody I told Lisa I look
get over it hugs all day and I've never
been so excited about one show obviously
when the guys when the guys came on last
year and they all booked I was super
excited because I know our dynamic but
is this this show is about greatness and
hearing greatness I feel like I'm
amongst my uncle's getting ready to hear
some great stories so I'm definitely
just excited about this I didn't think
we were gonna be able to get this all
together just because of scheduling but
man to put this all together and got it
in there by his own it oh it's just this
is it this is it rich this is the warm
iron well you've got the wingspan for
the group hog Kevin you can get them all
in there I know that what do you hope to
glean what might you not already know
that you hope to glean from this
conversation look anytime you get grapes
into the road
it's always about learning and I'm
always trying to understand I'm always
trying to understand what may Oscar a
great player I want to understand what
made George Gervin a great player what
the interaction between George Gervin
and dr. J the style the Flair your
vision who's your inspirations we've
heard this but you haven't had a sit
down to where you hear it from them in a
relaxed setting
in the setting of where you hear them
speak about today's game and the players
that they see emulate if not mimic
themselves their views on some of these
young guys the views on the game today
the views on the management of the game
like nobody's really taking the older
players as oh jeez who sat them down and
actually let them talk let them hear on
how the the league is creating no Oscar
Robinson was really the reason for free
agency these days no one really
who's that I was like a trivia question
that you asked you at Christmas or
Thanksgiving or something right you
don't know that I want to get into that
I want to hear those challenges I think
it's good to understand as a lead young
players in it to understand where you
coming from the things that come before
you
understanding that vision might not only
give you something but stimulate you in
another way to get you to think that wow
you know this is this is what come
before me and the appreciation that you
should have with that may I think that's
one of the lost things in the game but
I'm just gonna recirculate what I think
that everybody don't know and have a
great conversation and try to have a
great show well I look forward to that
Kevin Garnett's again area 21 with the
Big O dr. J the Iceman Bernard King and
Lisa Leslie that's on TNT on Thursday
night what do you think is the common
thread for greatness and how much do you
see that in the league today Kevin yeah
the attitude the perception you know
like attitude is everything I like to
say that the calming or I would like to
think that was calming today that was
very common back in dais their
competitiveness and wanting to be the
best the cream of the crop standing out
you know you're only going to have a
four or five great players you know back
in the days when those guys played with
reception of talent on your team they
had like four or five grapes on their
team you start to see today's game go
back to that three or four guys that you
got to have the major that could be
easily to start another team back in the
Lakers in in the 80s and 90s even before
that you had stacked kings where you
have big ole and you know currying a lot
of people don't know they had a hell of
a chance to go with their Milwaukee team
like like to go to these teams and see
the similarities in errors although we
don't like it because we won't
obviously talent to be spread out when
you think about when talent does get
together and be legendary like you know
like the Warriors are very similar to a
lot of teams that was in the ABA in the
early NBA other similarities there
people people not even putting those
together guess what I'm going to put
them together and then we're going to
talk about so I think there's a lot of
similarities
obviously a BA MBA to the common to the
president MBA well let's talk about one
team that does have a nice collection of
of all-star players the one in Oklahoma
City and obviously Oscar Robertson was
mentioned almost every day last year
because of what Russell Westbrook was
doing now you had Paul you add you know
you had Paul George Carmelo to the mix
and they are there 12 and 14 right now
kg why do you think that is
let me say something everybody man oh
this is my two cinemas bringing talent
together is one obstacle okay that's one
challenge getting that to be on the same
page as another challenge these are all
obstacles but as a team you figure it
out and that's what and that's how you
really grow listen nothing is instant
like coffee when it comes to putting
their chemistry or formula together OKC
is figuring this thing out what it is is
that everybody is expecting them to be a
ahead of the curve so to speak as far as
figuring it out and it's not that easy
they got to play defense they got to
figure out rotations they got to figure
out the roles on here you know it's not
just you coming to the gym hey I was
playing with you in the summertime now
ah now we have a system here and then
another thing too I don't know where I
don't ever want to go and get Billy
dollar he's a really really great coach
I really felt like he has the keys to it
but something it's not connecting they
have a disconnect somewhere and it's on
everybody and everybody has to look at
themselves in the mirror and I think
that they're thinking that they're
better than probably what they are and
they're not that good right now and they
got to face that but at the same time do
something about that and it's this much
as a challenge for everybody to figure
it out Cleveland had the same thing
can't tell me Cleveland how sublime
right look OKC has a bunch Brook you
know he can't tell me they were the
better team last year or less then there
there there they are worst team with
more that doesn't make any sense science
and that doesn't add up but it's on them
to figure it out and no one's gonna come
in here and feel sorry just going to be
a bunch of questions asked and
gotta be the ones to answer you just
can't figure things out sometimes too
how about this Kawhi Leonard comes back
and the Spurs loose in the Mavericks I
mean how does how do you even have two
together in comment with four on that
one Kevin listen I think we're putting
the expectancy of our star players or or
dynamic players because yeah he was
great he only played 16 minutes he had a
minute restriction now if he's played 39
minutes or 40 minutes that might be
different I don't know what what could
have happened but we'd have seen
probably 25 to 30 more minutes of him
performing that way you understand so I
think it's society and a little bit of
us expecting you know hey yeah best
player came back y'all should have won
well shoulda coulda woulda you know if
it was a split would be y'all F though
right the window you know they gotta
answer these questions though but it's
not an instant thing I think chemistry
is something that's totally underrated
um I think we put a lot of press on it
and we just got to give it time I think
OKC's gonna be a better team come to the
second half or that I'm hoping because
it takes you time to figure it out it's
a it's a real struggle yeah and then you
know obviously the Cavs starting poorly
and then they go on fire and then Isiah
Thomas is gonna come back how do you
think that's gonna how that's gonna be
transitioned will it be seamless so
we're gonna just see the same thing that
we've been talking about the past few
minutes Catholic Irish you ever watch
I don't watch too much of it but you
ever seen those shows where the the the
kind of the Nerds or the geeks have
these like motorized like tanks in them
made of layer the BattleBots the battle
battle they just running each other over
and the one who ever knocked over one
over and done I like it the league like
that Cleveland hat it's like that it's
like that big old armored little tank
that has a scope and all type of weapons
on it right hmm they're getting ready to
put another piece of weapon on top of
their tank and they have a closer in the
fourth quarter they have another force
that can give you something not only got
another facilitator another force that
they're getting ready to add into the
mix
Derrick Rome's coming back being more
mind and body coming back from injury
you're going to start to see these teams
get better and better and better for my
chemistry perspective
okay now whether that you know you know
it's gets you wins or losses whether it
reflects the winds the losses that I
don't know about that but I'm telling
our chemistry you want a strong bond
going into the playoffs and adding all
these pieces I T coming back around
Christmas beat Rose coming back shortly
out there maybe you're gonna start
seeing this team you want to start
expecting this team to be something
different just because of it so then
let's let's you know wrap things up by
continuing this battlebot conversation
the Cavs bot is gonna go against the
Celtics bot and the winner of that bot
is gonna go against the warrior bot give
me the bot that breaks this idea up as
we're sitting here right now
mid-december give me the bot that that
we're not expecting to be listen listen
listen the bot right now it won't be
don't be
Celtics this won't be um it's gonna
louse to be Cleveland mm-hmm
believe it or not Washington is gonna
make a run believe it they're going
through their struggles right now okay
colano is going to shock they're going
to continue to get better this is just
I'm throwing it yeah Houston it's going
to be there that bot is going to be
there the Warriors body is gonna be
there in OKC who's going to get it
together
he's still gonna have that back there
what about the Minnesota bot what about
Billy bot and you talked about the mini
Minnesota bot it's gonna you know on the
way in there but those bots are not
going away
what about the Lavar bot is that it
going to be in Lithuania or Los Angeles
that's got a way that's got to put some
more pieces on it's got a at you know
their wheels and it's dirty it's got to
kind of have a little more armor on it
you know right gotta get in the weight
room build a spot you know I'm Sarah
what would you think like what would
life been like for Kevin Garnett if you
were in Lithuania as a 16 year old what
would have been like for you taking Ben
a culture shock but I don't I don't know
my pops I've never had a dad oh no but I
like to think that his dad is doing
what's in the best interest of what he
feels is in the best interest for his
kids to succeed I don't like the talks
of
this man jello not having an opportunity
to make the league it seems like they're
already kind of blackballed and it's not
putting that out there that he's not
going to have a chance I think every kid
needs a chance to be able to see if he's
equipped to be able to be in the league
or not I don't think that you should put
a penalty or flaw in the kid just
because of something that he did in this
past I think you should give him a
chance to be able to grow and respect
that growth and I've been seeing a lot
of stuff out just in publications just
out in readings that
oh he's not good enough to be this he's
not good but he was good enough to go to
the UCLA and before he got in trouble he
was good enough to play so why he good
enough to go to the league now or even
have a chance to so I didn't understand
that now I just foresee a blackballing
coming just because of it
I'm a officers got a whole nother layer
of Zoning when the president got into it
and um I don't know I just want to see
him have a chance at but listen coaches
shot that would have been a coach's off
for me
it's still basketball and you got to
understand those are prideful players in
that lead and it's not all you know
glitz and glamour but if they will come
out of that better that come out
experienced and I like to think that
they would use that experience in their
futures and making some decisions for
themselves it's not all a bad thing
because it's gonna be an experiences
well we'll see Lonzo against the Cavs
and the Warriors hosting the Mavericks
that's the doubleheader tomorrow night
on TNT that includes an area 21 with you
Kevin Garnett Oscar Robertson dr. Jay
George Gervin Lisa Leslie and again once
again a nice big hug for me to Bernard
King please I'm definitely gonna do that
excellent bridge thank you for having me
now much hot dogs yes
wingspan it I can't wait to see that kg
thanks to the call as always we'll chat
soon that's Kevin Garnett at cagey area
21 the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience